halloween special
here in this video we will try and list
down 10 of the scariest scps found in
the internet right now
scps are fictional anomalies creatures
and objects that are just unnatural to
be explained in simple terms anyway for
this halloween we have searched the net
and here is our pick so subscribe if you
haven't and now let's get down to
business
at number 10 we have scp-087 the
stairwell
scp-087 is a dark and platform stairwell
as stairs that fall at a 38 degree
inclination for about 13 steps to a
semi-circular platform with a diameter
of around 3 meters subjects report
hearing disturbed vocalizations of what
they believe to be a sobbing child and
audio recordings back up their claims
however as one descends the steps they
discover that there is no end in sight
and come face to face with a terrifying
creature a male with no nose pupils nor
mouth
number nine
scp-049 the plague doctor
scp-049 is a humanoid being with the
appearance of a plague doctor from the
middle ages through direct skin contact
scp-049 has the ability to disable an
organism's biological functioning
scp-049 adrenaline and endorphin levels
skyrocketed after a particular operation
and now it attempts to kill any human
being it can locate before reverting to
its mindless state and then wandering
around until it encounters more humans
number eight
scp-096 the shy guy this gaunt hairless
humanoid with long gangly arms and legs
is typically as docile as they can come
but it has a single trigger anyone who
looks at its face well the face in
question features blank eyes and a mouth
that can stretch up to five times the
size of a normal human's mouth but the
problem is that once anyone sees his
face even through any kind of media or
photos nothing will stop it from coming
to kill a person
ripping them to shreds
at number 7 we have
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile this
scp as stated in the name cannot be
killed even with the most powerful
weapons and techniques it just becomes
incapacitated for a while and adapts to
the attacks making it invulnerable the
next time
scp-682 is a large vaguely reptile-like
creature of unknown origin it appears to
be extremely intelligent and appears to
have a hatred for all life which has
been expressed by it in several
interviews during containment
number six scp-2317k
the devourer of worlds
although
scp-2317 is a doorway to another
dimension the scariest thing about it is
that there is a creature locked up in it
also known as the great devourer it is
reported to have an obese human-like
shape with branch-like horns sprouting
from its head and no lower jaw it is
estimated to be over 200 kilometers tall
when standing fully erect and it is
entirely covered in overlapping
plate-like scales this creature when let
loose will bring about the end of the
world
number five scp-4975
times up
scp-4975 is a humanoid entity with avian
features the most prominent of them
which is a beak
it has a long slender general body
structure and its limbs taper off into
formless extremities with no
identifiable digits its cervical
vertebrae does not appear to be
interconnected and appears to move
independently of the others
this scp will stalk a human for days
weeks or months on end and the person
will keep on hearing a crackling sound
from behind which is the sound of the
scp's vertebrae and when it stops
suddenly the creature will attack the
victim and kill it
number 4
scp-966 sleep killer scp-966 are
predatory animals with an extended face
and a mouth laced with needle like fangs
that resemble hairless digital humans
they do not appear to rest while
sleeping instead they will suddenly stop
moving for around 5 minutes or so and
then continue when they hunt they emit a
single burst of wave that restricts a
person's sleep
and sleep deprived victims of scp-966
show signs of suffering from extreme
hallucinations and when they are too
weak
due to lack of rest the sap will consume
them
number 3
scp-1548 ex the hateful star
just like coming straight out of a
lovecraft cosmic horror story this next
scp gives us the ultimate creeps and
sends shivers to anyone who would hear
its message
also known as the hateful star it is a
sentient star-like entity devoting to
hatred of all forms currently moving
towards the solar system to destroy
earth located 24 light years away this
scp sends a radio message saying that it
will kill all human life and the
scariest thing about this is that there
is no way of stopping a star hell
hellbent on destroying the solar system
number 2
scp-106 the old man
the scp-106 creature has the appearance
of an elderly man with a perpetual
sinister smile and empty eyes coated in
black muck the old man is a malevolent
and predatory creature with the capacity
to walk through walls flows and hang
from ceilings and its slime is a
universal decomposer everything it comes
into contact with rust rots or cracks
the fact that he has a power over a
pocket dimension is his most terrifying
power in that realm he has complete
control over space and time and this
favorite pastime is pulling any human in
it
for games called chase in which it will
hunt down and torment them and kill them
just for joy
and number one scp uncategorized scarlet
king it was dubbed as scp-001 for a
while but it was taken down as it is
deemed to be too mysterious and unknown
to be classified as any number at all
there have been various stories about
the scarlet king's beginnings due to a
lack of cannon in the sap universe he
declared himself the king of the
darkness below vowing to destroy the
tree the creator and creation itself as
well as consume or subjugate all other
gods he launched a war on creation
itself a war that will last till the end
of time he is the ultimate evil and
hatred incarnate and has the power that
is incomprehensible to any human here is
the end of all and that is why he gets
the number one spot
and so with that we come to the end of
the video do remember to hit that like
button for support and subscribe to be a
part of the mind cue family also ring
that bell button for regular updates
when we post new monster content right
here on this channel till the next one
have a great halloween